[Music]
welcome everybody it is the History
podcast we are here it is Friday Baby
Woo
yes yes join our today's episode is
sponsored by honey and Native who we
love and today we're joined by The
elusive Anthony and I say elusive
because we've been trying to get you on
the show for a long time but I'm happy
to see that that you're out here in LA
and we're making it happen and it's nice
to finally meet you in person I know we
can touch each other yeah we can touch
each other for the first time now we
were just talking before we went live
and I actually wanted to ask you an
update yeah you eat one meal a day just
lunch I I eat lunch and dinner I skip
breakfast well breakfast is usually just
like a lot of tea just a lot of tea
there's a lot of tea it's a lot of green
tea yeah and so
um okay so you're doing two meals so
that's not that end yeah yeah two meals
and then kind of snacking throughout the
day too oh wow okay okay yeah good yeah
wow all right yeah I'm off to a riveting
beginning here yeah I'm Reinventing the
the the the meal plan yeah well some
people say that breakfast is the most
important meal of the day 8 but other
people say it is not your thoughts I'm
one of those people I guess I'm one of
the people that say it isn't there it is
guys all right thanks for watching
that's a wrap Anthony of course I'm sure
many of you know uh is a music reviewer
here on YouTube and
I don't even want to necessarily blow
smoke up your ass but I don't know that
there's another music reviewer today who
has the I don't I don't know if
influence is the right word but like the
Pres the presence right the respect I've
worked hard for the respect what little
there is there's a little I've worked
hard for you do you agree with that
statement
um generally speaking Yeah I often don't
get the chance to take a lot of time to
sit back and think about everything that
I've
accomplished overall this time there was
actually a viewer of mine that dmed me
this morning and said something like
I'm pretty sure you've reviewed over 3
000 albums since you've started the
YouTube that's crazy and I've said are
you serious and he said well since about
2009 2010 you've been you've been
reviewing like about Five albums a day I
mean a week and I looked at my YouTube
on my main channel uh you know video
count it says it's around it's just
under four thousand damn and you know I
even sort of lowballed it a little bit
and I did four times you know 52 for you
know uh so many years since I've started
and um yeah I mean it came out to just
around like under three three k so if
you're reviewing that many albums and
you say you do about five four to five a
week four or five a week so how much
time do you think you need to spend
listening to an album before you feel
like I can judge the quality of this I
know for myself that sometimes I listen
to music and the first few listens I'm
not into it and Russia that's a common
phenomenon right yeah and then as you
listen to it more or more you you like
it more I don't know if that means it's
better or you're just more familiar with
this so much so much enjoyment with
music generally has to do with
familiarity and recognition of patterns
right be they melodic repetition or
rhythmic repetition whatever it is and
sometimes especially with genres or
styles of music that are foreign to you
you do need to kind of revisit with them
and listen to them a bunch of times
before you get into it yeah so do you
feel you're able to do that though if
you're reviewing basically one album
every day and a half I I would say yes
especially considering that like
there's a pretty narrow view or at least
to me a narrow view of popular music
genres that I'm reviewing week to week I
mean you know no matter what it is I'm
covering it's pretty much guaranteed to
either be a rock pop metal hip-hop album
maybe an electronic record maybe a jazz
record something like that you know as
long as it's within those confines I'm
pretty comfortable with like you know
what I'm hearing and where everything is
at how things musically or
compositionally are operating
um sometimes if I'm sort of listening
outside of that uh or if I'm listening
to something that's super avant-garde or
experimental or if maybe there's like a
really huge uh out there deep layered
concept to a record that I'm reviewing
I'll probably need more time with it you
know maybe a couple of days I see yeah
and um
um actually we have a special guest here
should we bring them out real fast oh
it's it's it's not it's just Gabe it's
white Club Gabe he calls in every Friday
I love Jade yeah you know about White
Flag I do know that if I I follow Gabe
honestly yeah he's a great guy he calls
in every Friday to wish us a happy
Friday Gabe what's going on with the
hair gray or bleach what's going on
my head I'm going Platinum with my hair
Platinum baby yeah oh oh someone's
getting their hair done right behind you
what's going on
that's my hair stylist oh you're at the
salon right now
yeah [__] many [__]
just got my head again heading to the
batting cages
I'm going batting and all Platinum
that's what the [__] is up baby because
it's Friday because eat my [__]
spending the night eat my [__]
yes I do want to review that Diddy
um
you could use a verse we need a verse we
need it we need some bars Gabe are you
do you know who Anthony fantano is
Pantano no I don't think so you're not
on his radar I'm not yeah I'm not
that's how we judge how famous our
guests are whether or not I apologize
that's true I reveal that he's a legend
thank you he's a uh famous and prominent
music reviewer
and Gabe do you what's your favorite
song Maybe we can maybe we could get his
feedback on that do you have a favorite
album band or song how about two Live
Crew
yeah it doesn't surprise me that Gabe
would be into two Live Crew given the
content also I I'm just remembering now
I uh did a tick tock duet where Gabe was
singing like a hot dog song okay and
there were maybe three other people
playing on it and then I added Bass to
it okay okay so you guys are some you
guys have met in a way yeah yeah
digitally over Tick Tock yeah okay Gabe
well that sounds really nice it sounds
like you have a nice Friday there and
I'm happy to hear it you know
[Music]
why don't you [__] my [__] open
eyeball [__]
my tits cheating my eyes
it sucks it's boring oh you know what I
gotta touch on this Gabe has been on a
whole Crusade against Avatar and I think
that's such a Vibe it's a worthy cause
yeah I'm not a avatar fan I did not like
the first one there's a lot of people
trying to influence me to get me watch
the second one so far I'm on a strike
okay Gabe I can't get this storyline of
Avatar I'd say it's boring yeah it's
boring Puss in Boots is the real deal I
can get with [__] Puss in Boots the cat
poop on an adventure it's more exciting
that's what the [__] is up dude we gotta
puss in a boot and he's got a Rapier
actually I heard puss and boost is
really good but yeah
let me check the reviews on Puss in
Boots too because I actually heard that
was a banger what's the Rotten Tomatoes
score that's what I'm looking up right
now right so we need 95 y'all I'm
telling you Puss in Boots is a Bop
meanwhile Gabe if you got going over to
Avatar 2
on Rotten Tomatoes 77 percent
the verdict is in Gabe is right again
hmm
that's some boots is the winner baby
yeah [__] in my boots [__]
[__] in my mouth
ah yes yo game game [__] in the ocean
and then scoop it up because that's what
I don't know Avatar they live underwater
right do they just took human-sized [__]
out in the water they live above water
oh that's what I heard that it all takes
place underwater maybe in the second one
yeah the second one isn't that right Ian
who else saw it Daniel's not here I saw
it yes uh they they they still live
above the water they just swim a lot so
do they are swimming so do they go
swimming quite a bit because they're
actually much larger than humans right
they're like 10 feet they are like nine
or ten feet so do they take massive
giant humanoid shits they do yeah
there's about there's about a swim
sequence in the second act that ain't
that ain't right
okay
all right Gabe listen it sounds like
your Friday is going great I want it to
keep going great okay bud
who the [__] is Uncle Gabe who the [__]
is Uncle Gabe who the [__] is okay
all right Gabriel
good talking to you
all right
that sounds like that could be the he's
the best is he not oh no it's it's great
that sounds like it could be the bridge
to the the refrain earlier that he was
singing yeah put them together for a
remix yeah and you know I apologize to
anyone who comes on the show on Friday
it's not up to me he just calls in on
Friday no I understand I'm a guest yeah
yeah I'm a guest in these hallowed halls
and I'm just I'm just operating within
the Paradigm that's already here before
I came in but I'm glad you know you're
familiar with the lore you know yeah
so let's see here
um
you know we are kind of on the same
watch list I don't know if you knew that
uh like FBI watch no like the the
Neo-Nazi kill list I don't know oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah worst people in the world
Paul Joseph Watson yeah uh Joseph Stalin
made that that one I'm down with I
haven't heard from Paul in a while I
don't know what's going on with him wait
did something happen to him
no I'm he's been a little dormant lately
at least in terms of turning up in my
DMs or not my DMs but my mentions yeah
no me too although my mentions are so
[__] on Twitter now like they're
actually honestly literally everyone has
them yeah like has has a badge but um so
yeah he's he's like a radical uh right
wing provocateur I'm gonna stop dissing
the Nazis all the time yeah he's that
he's kind of down with that ideology so
just Stalin I get right I mean Hillary
Clinton
I don't know if she's up there with the
greats but yeah is she up there with
Stalin I don't know but not really right
not a bit of an overestimation Anthony
fantana
I'm definitely worse than Hillary
Clinton I mean I I I'll I'll give him
that I mean how many how many [__] up
bad reviews have you done
you know how many people have you heard
you know in Cedar Rapids it's my girl
oh then so then there's Ethan Klein of
course that's right the end you're
you're a second thought to me I I come
above you I'm worse and uh Mark
Zuckerberg is on here George Bush right
interestingly uh Hitler is missing from
the uh list oh yeah I mean Hitler is
missing from the list which is kind of
like a layup for this kind of list
but so there you go when did you become
like uh
why did all these guys hate you why do
all these right-wing guys hate you
because I know that's a thing do you
talk about politics a lot like what
happened here on Twitter sometimes
um because I'm just not really
apologetic about it I mean I I went to
school for political science among other
things and I'm just opinionated on these
topics and on top of it I think at least
I
I think a lot of people wouldn't
necessarily see or think of Music
reviews as like something that is
inherently political but I mean a lot of
the artists that I review come from
either an impoverished impoverished
background or they are addressing
systemic issues in their music or their
queer or they're trans or they're uh
women singing or you know making art
about their experiences as women and
oftentimes
um uh I have to kind of address that in
the reviews to the best of my ability as
somebody who obviously hasn't lived that
experience and um you know and and try
to take account of of what that means
for the art that I'm listening to and um
and and as a result of that sometimes
there's
commenters that are like uh you're just
giving this a pass because a woman
you're just giving this pass because
it's a a black rapper you're just giving
this a pass because it's this or that or
the other thing and um you know I'm not
really uh uh you know hiding the ball
when it comes to my opinions about those
people either in my content or on social
media because a lot of the time I would
much rather not be seeing those comments
or dealing with those people and I feel
like at least for me personally the best
way to deal with that is just to be as
loud and as annoying and you want them
to leave yeah yeah I want them to [__]
off and you know die in a ditch
somewhere and you know but unfortunately
sort of like being public about that
also means that guys like Paul can you
know see those comments and you know uh
uh and and often will respond to them to
sort of like you know create a frenzy
among all their little in-cell followers
on the internet I also did a video about
Paul once where he was like making a lot
of just very misinformed uh you know
calls on
art and a host of other things I was
actually going to do a follow-up once
where I believe he said something to the
note of like
remember when Ariana Grande had like
that concert of hers like bombed yes or
whatever he had made some comments to
note of like well how can you blame
these terrorists when you know it's like
so much of our media is just a really
[__] and just like you know nude women
around everywhere and so on and so forth
can you pull that up that receipt I I
it's interesting how the conservative
movement in this country is getting
closer and closer to the Taliban as time
goes on and in fact now they're like you
see the Taliban is like yo let's free
Andrew Tate and a bunch of conservatives
guys are like based Taliban so there is
like a converging they're coming
together right
[__] yes no there is I mean if you kind
of dial the clock back into the 90s or
2000s
the conservative movement would have
never stood up for a guy who who was
essentially a pimp you know and and
Andrew Tate is nothing more than sort of
a lowly internet pimp and um you know
because of the life that he leads and
how promiscuous and uh so on and so
forth it tends to be uh never would he
be seen as sort of like a moral leader
but the culture War has shifted in such
a way where uh most focus and defense
needs to go on to defending masculinity
and they see him as a defender of
traditional masculinity of patriarchy so
of course like they need to get behind
him in order to you know sort of like I
guess keep that ball rolling do you
think that
um reviewing all this amount of Music
That's you said a lot of it is kind of
like socially aware or commentary do you
think the music has changed you at all
and listening to it or do you think you
bring your your perspective from outside
of the music you consume
um I think some of the commentary has
exposed me to
experiences and points of view that I
don't think I not not that I wouldn't
have been exposed to otherwise but you
know uh hearing an artist or hearing
like obviously before reviewing two
pimpa butterfly or reviewing sinner get
ready I I was well aware of you know
things like um uh you know uh domestic
abuse women within relationships or you
know various systematic inequities or
economic inequities between you know
white communities and black communities
and so on and so forth but
um you know hearing it from the
perspective
you know but but I like most people
don't necessarily get emotionally
whipped up reading that stuff in a book
in terms of like statistics you know for
a lot of people it hits home when you
hear someone's personal lived experience
dealing with it you know and um you know
and in that sense I'm not different than
anybody else and uh you know hearing it
again from someone's own lived
experience you know certain certainly
says something it's it it allows you to
sort of make an emotional attachment to
it you know uh rather than just sort of
like looking at it as kind of like you
know this large-scale statistical issue
um but I I guess uh you know hearing it
come from a more personal place it does
mean something
and so do you happen to listen to any
pro white uh race stuff for you just
pick it one side like uh no I can't I
mean I I guess I guess if I am listening
to it I'm laughing at it yeah I I guess
I'm very biased you are biased again I
am biased basically I I I'll admit I'm
biased against any music that is
pro-white power okay there you guys
heard it here he is a biased biased
music reviewer yeah basically basically
any any white power music I come across
I don't cover or it gets a very very
negative score so does that mean that
you don't [__] with country music
no no I review quite a bit of country
you do because I I just noticed that
when you were listing the genres you're
comfortable with you didn't say country
music but you like country music I do
like country music um I was just I just
reviewed uh a record not too long ago
from this artist named the artist uh who
I was really
enjoying their new record uh white trash
revelry is quite good though I don't
know if you could uh necessarily kind of
categorize the measure typically typical
country artists because they are sort of
like they're they're non-binary and a
lot of their songs are sort of like
written from the standpoint of like a
queer experience
um and I was also listening to um uh
this artist Zach Bryan today who I think
is uh
quite good I think it's got a great
voice not necessarily like the most um
uh novel instrumentals out there that
I've heard in modern country music but
it doesn't sound like the super
corporatized [__] that you hear
oftentimes uh Chris Stapleton I think is
an amazing singer
um uh Sturgill Simpson I like as well
though I I feel like the more that he
goes on uh he tends to
put out a lot of records that are
experimenting outside of country even
though that's where like a lot of his
roots are I see him really as kind of
like an artist artist in terms of like
he wants to do a little bit of
everything
um so uh no I I have no qualms with
country music I think uh it's just not
necessarily what's the most demanded
among my audience and when I do run
across something that I want to cover
it's it's definitely got to be something
I'm passionate about and I want it and I
want to like you know talk about and
sort of maybe turn my audience onto does
it blow this blows my mind country music
is the most popular genre of music in
America isn't that right or is it now
hip-hop I I think it's been Hip Hop for
a minute now yeah
so but isn't like Garth Brooks like the
biggest selling artist in American
history like what is I mean I don't even
know one I mean there was there was
there was a country boom in in the 90s
that I'm sure you remember when we were
kids like all over the radio
um and and look they're still pockets of
the country where country music is still
you know very hot and very relevant
um country music's not going anywhere
you know I mean if anything's happening
there is
uh with with more of the country music
Audience getting online and getting onto
the internet you're starting to like
with other genres we've seen as of late
um you're starting to see an evening of
the playing field in terms of like
artists that are a little bit more in it
for the art and are more independent and
are more underground and are trying to
operate out of the Nashville system
um and do their own thing uh country
just happens to be one of the you know I
guess um uh last popular music genres to
kind of do it you know we've seen it
with rock music we've seen it with Indie
music we've seen it with hip-hop over
the past 10 years as well
um you know dudes who are basically the
goats of this generation like Kendrick
Lamar Danny Brown so on and so forth all
of them started you know completely on
this underground independent track you
know um and then sort of grew up from
there
um you know they they didn't come in
Industry endorsed in the way that like
you know
um 56 when he dropped you know get rich
or die trying you know it already had
like that Dre cosine and the Eminem
cosine and everything like that you know
Kendrick had to drop section 80 prove
himself
um and you know 50 had his mixtape days
before all that as well you know but but
the thing is like it was just a
different time you know the internet has
ushered in a new era um of artistry of
Independence and I think we're starting
to see that shift with country music and
starting to see a blend of that genre
with other Styles as well because you
see these country artists working with
these snap beats what some of the genre
refer to as where it's just like a
hip-hop beat it's just like an r b yeah
but they're just you know throwing like
her you know sort of like country draws
on top of it and you're also seeing you
know fusions with pop and Hip-Hop from
the other side like Lil Nas X you know
like Old Town Road and you know so on
and so forth so this was like the
biggest song of the I mean it's it's the
longest running number one scene yeah
it's great it's crazy yeah and it's and
which is you know crazy thinking crazy
crazy but also makes sense because I
mean as an American song it appeals to
those biggest popular music genres it's
a pop song It's A hip-hop song and it's
a country song all wrapped in one did we
ever get any what did like True Country
fans think of that song I don't know
that I ever saw
any opinions on that if they like that
if they're like this [__] um I think uh
the the song definitely had a hard time
being accepted within that Community uh
off the bat because if I remember there
was
um either the charts or some institution
was not taking it seriously as a country
song even though it was doing really
well numbers wise but then you had you
know Billy Ray Cyrus come in and do like
the you know the feature which kind of
like opened the door for it to have that
appeal within the country Community
which I think was was nice of him and
also smart of him to yeah to do frankly
yeah what do you think about country
artists Oliver tree
uh
um not a country artist I'm a fan of but
I I you know Oliver tree I think uh
likes Sturgill Simpson he's an artist
artist and he wants to do a little bit
of everything he's got his errors he's
got his evolutions he's like Madonna
he's like a post-modern Madonna without
the talent well you know without a lot
and like a virgin we don't need to list
the things he doesn't have in comparison
to Madonna you know right but we we can
just celebrate him for the things he has
in common with have you rated Oliver's
albums uh yeah his his country record
and the one before that yeah so would it
do you remember what you gave them I
gave his debut a seven which he was not
generous and um and then I gave his
country album much much much much much
lower well tell me what it was well I
think it was maybe around the realm of a
three or yeah what the [__] if I was
yeah and and frankly a seven is pretty
generous that that's a high score in
fantastic world it was but he was still
very angry about it yeah he's a [__]
weirdo yeah I heard he's just I was just
gonna make a horrible joke I met him
it was very nice even a light three yeah
you won't even go
mid or strong on the three no we went
light on it yeah very light on it yeah
you know what I'm captivating oh here I
want to pull this up real fast
um
here's the Tweet just just don't call
back here's Paul Joseph Watson because I
I love always to point out the depravity
of these [__] these [__] freaks
uh she said I am in tears this is
utterly terrifying there was a terrorist
attack at her concert he said no Ariana
what's utterly terrifying is your fans
being blown up by a terrorist wait I'm
confused isn't that what she said yeah
so what's his point yeah what is what is
the argument what is it what's on our
game page they're they're in agreement
but yeah he's framing it as if
they're disagreeing no they're on the
same yeah I think you all are on the
same page here Paul yeah I'm pretty sure
Ariana is sad about her fans being
attacked by a terrorist as well does he
think that she's just like I'm scared
and I don't care what happens to them
because that's reading a lot into yeah
it's reading a lot into that yeah okay
actually let's see what he's up to I'm
curious because oh Jesus Christi oh he's
still out there oh my God is he out
there oh wait no see that's views not
nobody's listening to [__]
let's see surprise he's hitting on gay
people the arranged reaction to Ivan Pro
provo's refusal to bow to coercion to
endorse his LGBT due to religious
beliefs whatever gives a [__] freak you
live in your hate I mean it sounds like
he's just pretty much hopped onto the
same you know anti-lgbt narrative that
they're all on right now that's pretty
much the whole bandwagon right now yeah
yeah a while ago a while ago it was all
immigration it was all the Caravan and
now it's like uh if you're an ally to
lgbtq people or if you are lgbtq you're
a groomer right right that's the vibe
also trans athletes is a Vibe yeah yeah
no that's yeah that was that was a song
they were singing for a bit too I really
sometimes fantasize about making a
conservative Channel and because I feel
like it's such an easy grip and like
they lay out the cultural War so nice
for you I want to make an anonymous
Channel don't show my face get big
enough to get a contract from the daily
wire for 50 million dollars
and then just be like yo it's me it's
it's me it's been not the whole time
gotcha but it doesn't matter because I
probably would radicalize millions of
people and got like dozens of gay people
murdered
I mean right that's what they do
anyway
um where were we
uh we were talking about country uh is
there any categories of music you don't
[__] with
um I don't really review much if any
classical music there's like some modern
classical and minimalism stuff that I
reviewed before but uh you know as far
as classical music goes I'll admit it
I'm pretty much like out of my depth
yeah there's some that I enjoy but like
going about critiquing it and telling
you what works what doesn't what's mid
what's great what's Superior what's
inferior I I couldn't even begin to tell
you is there still a vibrant new music
scene for classical music I think with
classical music like with um
a lot of jazz frankly
um the much of the scene has sort of
like
I don't want to say died off it's still
there it still exists I mean truth be
told like the thing that keeps any music
movement relevant is that it has new
young blood in it willing to try
something new and do something different
classical music unfortunately has kind
of like lost the plot in terms of like
making its scene translate to the Next
Generation and um as a result of that
you know a lot of that scene is uh just
being kept Alive by either you know
um uh musicians who basically study the
craft and uh you know various
educational institutions which
is fine it's good that it's still there
as far as like you know an access point
like somebody should be keeping the
torch Burning uh if it's gonna be them I
mean fine cool okay but that's not
exactly like driving excitement to the
genre yeah that makes sense um so I mean
you know I I guess in a way it's got
kind of a PR issue but simultaneously uh
I think the people operating within the
scene are typically purists who kind of
want you know things to maybe stay the
same or focus on the same tenets and
artists and pieces that have always been
focused on because that that's the thing
like if you're going to have excitement
in your genre and you're going to have
that you know younger crowd of people
come in and do something different try
something different you have to also be
willing to be open to the change that
they're going to bring to the table you
know which I think rock also has an
issue with these days really yeah you
know I think there's
um a lot of discussion among Rock Fans
that are kind of just stuck in the past
honestly you know they want to talk
about like
Led Zeppelin they want to talk about the
Beatles they want to talk about this and
that and they want to Champion bands
like Greta Van Fleet or that just sound
like a [__] Led Zeppelin cover you
don't like Greta I know it's
controversial no I I don't care for Fred
and is there regreta van Fleek fan in
here no I said I [__] show yourself I
hated them it's one of them That's a
hardcore rocker yeah what do you yeah I
I don't let I don't get it personally
but I know a lot of people like it yeah
but yeah it seems very uh derivative
yeah and you know even guys like the way
he sings is like bro yeah and and even
guys like um you know Jack White for
example uh who you know in in a lot of
ways for a long time has championed a
lot of those old school rock Aesthetics
in terms of like garage rock and blues
and so on and so forth uh when he puts
out a record where he's experimenting
and doing something different like um
you know one of his recent ones where he
was doing some electronic stuff or even
his two sister albums that he put out
recently I mean whenever he tries to do
something weird or experimental a little
you know kind of like off the beaten
path his fans freak at least some of
them do because yeah why doesn't it
sound like a white stripes record or why
doesn't it just sound like you know an
old school blues record or whatever and
it's like geez like give the guy some
breathing room to like push the genre
forward because he's one of the few
people in the mainstream that's actually
relevant and is a rock artist you know
actually kind of pushing things forward
or being willing to take a risk or do
something you know left field
you know uh something interesting a
mutual friend of ours uh logic uh you
notoriously hate his [__] music some
of it some of it so some of it not all
of it and and so well okay but it's it's
interesting to me how you have this
before you guys became friendly I don't
know friendly I don't know that it's
very friendly let's say friendly I don't
know the depth of your uh relationship
but before you guys started like
chatting and being being friendly right
you were kind of had a reputation for
just [__] hating his music so what is
that like when you go from like hating
someone's music and then trying to
connect with them personally I know for
you it's not personal right but he's got
and some level he's got to be like hmm
I I know personally for me it's not
really any big deal because like however
I feel about your music personally has
nothing to however I feel about your
music has nothing to do with how I feel
about you personally the the only way in
which I guess like
we could get into that territory is if
you are personally speaking a shitty
person and you make songs about how
shitty you are okay you know I mean thus
far logic hasn't made a record about how
much of a dirt bag he is and nor do I
think he is one yeah so it's like you
know his music doesn't really force me
to contend with his quality as a person
you know I whenever I listen to his
records I contend with the quality of
the art that I'm listening to you know
be that
um a record-like uh Under Pressure which
I thought was pretty good no pressure
which I thought was much better his
recent vinyl days record which I thought
was a a pretty good what was the grocery
store one yeah that was Superman
that one I just said it was not good not
good not good and what does that mean
when you say not good you're like it
doesn't even hit the Spectrum yeah it's
it's just basically a total non-starter
not even like like it's not even in the
realm of professional music I would it
could be professional but it's it's just
a non-starter in terms of like it's a
bad idea like how did we even get
there's no Foundation logic doing a bad
Rock album with like some Mac DeMarco
and Red Hot Chili Peppers impersonations
on it no we're just we're just not I
might call them illogical
it would be oh thanks he's fast on that
side thank you sir yeah you know but but
the thing is a good guy though really
nice guy nice guy and and I can respect
the fact that like he you know look I
mean
he's made millions and millions and
millions of dollars doing what he's
doing yeah and he could have continued
on the same exact track
um just kind of doing that forever but
he got to a point where personally
artistically speaking he got fed up with
kind of chasing after the you know the
billboard carrot and um good for him you
know it resulted in some records that
were kind of crappy
[Music]
um but uh you know at least he's willing
to try some different [__] you know
here's an interesting One Chance the
Rapper was huge coming up right and he
dropped a few albums that were awesome
like it was coloring book and then what
was the one after that that was that was
exclusive it was acid wrapped it was
covering both yeah after that one there
was another good one wasn't there I'm
trying to remember but but like though
he had he had like that mixtape era and
then the big day was supposed to be his
commercial album so so I I'm really
captivated by his story because like he
was coming up everyone was talking about
him he was popping and then he dropped
the album that was so [__] bad that
literally
everybody just said nah yeah and he's
gone they're like nah bro you're done
yeah he's just is that like falling off
the map and so it's unfortunate because
I do think there's like a lot of
a lot of talent there you know but the
thing is like the big day is just not
really
it's not a great album in fact it's a
Bad album but simultaneously it's it's
not the album that I I think his fans
wanted or were expecting you know and
it's just like a big hulking
mess of [__] in a way you know it's like
it's not paired down it's not focused
there's no Direction so many of the
verses are bad and so many of the
one-liners are corny and there's a lot
of bum ass instrumentals on the record
too and um you know for whatever reason
the focus that he had on Acid Rap and
the focus that he had on coloring book
was just kind of lost in this album that
was just like a shotgun spray where
nothing really landed have you ever seen
an artist like that though where they're
like they're on the come up and they
just drop something so [__] bad that
everyone just abandons them you know
what I mean I know it's happened before
I'm like failing to come up with a
laundry list but the thing is like
rarely has it happened
as badly in that in that context and
rarely has it
um happened at such a mainstream level
pretty incredible you know what I mean
yeah I mean sometimes uh people kind of
Crash and Burn however but with that
being said like there's loads of artists
that have dropped like records that were
absolutely hated by their fan base Kid
Cudi for example you know if you drop
that speeding bullet to Heaven record
which was like his own rock attempt at a
rock record uh which a lot of his fans
hated but he's dropped a bunch of
material since then that his fans have
loved and received well and you know I
think if Chance the Rapper still wants a
career at this point
it's really just up to him to come out
with more music it's true if he drops a
good album people will listen yeah
people people will still listen to it
people turn around and you know try him
again he's actually put out a handful of
singles since then which were pretty
good but the thing is like what
everybody's waiting for is a record you
know and there's like no sign of that
happening necessarily yeah you think it
just hit him that hard I really have no
idea you know man it's been a while I
mean it hasn't stopped him from coming
out with those songs so I mean was in
2019 it's been four years I mean
everything just pre-pandemic feels
much further away time-wise than it
actually is sometimes here's logic by
the way he wrote this lyric about you
feel it in my bald spot Anthony fantano
you plaid shirt wearing [__] Ayo
hey I used to hate you because you [__]
on my music but now we homies I take
your criticism and use it and use it is
that a good Rhyme or a little corny this
whole verse is a [__] cornfield but
let's go
see I love that you can you even hate
the nod to you this whole verse was like
subsidized by the government that's
[__] corn seal this this was made
into ethanol oh [__] this verse this
[__] verse was made into corn flakes
a whole a whole a whole year supply of
the entire logic I hope you're taking
his criticism and using it uh as you say
I used to fantasize about murdering
murdering now that's a that's a bit much
you know he I I'm trying to we we did
have some phone conversations I'm trying
to recall if
if he said that to me or if this verse
was the first time that that he that I
heard that from him and that's genuine
he told you I want I want to think he
did tell me over the phone like my
reviews made him very upset and that
sometimes he would be writing in the
studio and he'd be like
I want to say this but what's Anthony
fantano going to think about it and oh
and I literally you're in his head and I
literally said to him don't give a [__]
don't give a [__] about what I think
you know it's like I'm not I'm not
saying this is like a communication to
you personally you know
um if you feel like you know I I feel
like and I've said this before in videos
the artists struggle is to whatever idea
that it is that you have in your head
you figure out a way to make it manifest
in real life you know be it sort of like
a visual on a canvas or the certain
sound of a beat or you know a musical
composition whatever
that's that's the struggle if you feel
like you've adequately
taken an idea in your head that you're
passionate about and you've translated
it accurately to whatever medium it is
that you're doing and and I feel like
logic has I mean you know I think uh I
think expresses himself pretty clearly
you know I don't think he's a guy who's
uh you know has any lack of
communication skills when it comes to
his medium I think it's you know really
at the end of the day kind of a matter
of like taste you know aesthetically and
message wise I don't really you know
Vibe sometimes with the stuff that he's
putting across because again I do think
it is a little corny like in in in this
sense but uh we have a suggestion from
the audience oh what is a Logix debut
country album called corn-filled
subsidies
[Music]
sorry logic we love you bud
uh don't kill Anthony don't kill me
please it's not worth it
but you'd get in his head you probably
do get another people's head and we saw
that with from Drake in a way which
we'll get into later yeah I'm also
worried about like I'm killing me too
but like in a way you really get in
people's heads and uh
I find that very interesting because I
don't think there's other critics that
have that ability because traditionally
critics they writing and they're in word
and they're printed and it's like who
gives a [__] especially these days but
they got you got Clips bro you know what
I mean yeah like that hits hard yeah are
you are you dropping a double entender
like I got video clips but then I also
got people
are you armed like I'm unloading the
clip are you armed I'm not armed no okay
let's check in
I read the sign outside that this is a
gun-free zone
thank you yeah or like a we're like a
wild west uh split or platoon Saloon
yeah Saloon yeah yeah
foreign
let me continue this he says choking you
to death choking you to death and
watching from your point of view till we
got friendly so you see I assume he's
not saying he choked you till you loved
him wait choking you I'm I'm actually
this is hitting me for the first time
choking you to death and watching from
your point of view he wants to choke me
to death but then he's fantasizing as me
watching him choking sounds Inky yeah it
does actually kind of sound kinky it
sounds like he wants to get off on the
idea of watching him choke I like that
me he says and I realized he wasn't ever
trying to end me I was not one night
midnight 22 on the phone you said the
wildest [__] that solidified me to Stone
this
I just uh looked at him in the eye and
he turned a rock
you said you're really testing this
Theory right now right I am he's like
yeah it's not it's all good yeah you're
like nah [__] you suck bro no I'm just
kidding I'm putting words in your mouth
um
you said you said I built an amazing fan
base and career that's nobody debates
that that's true undebatable I'm
successful and I'm [__] worthy to be
here well of course yeah
and I you know I I feel the same way
about all artists who uh I review for
the most part you know it's it's very
rare that even if it's something that I
hate
and I don't enjoy at all that I I feel
internally like you don't deserve to
have the success that you have you know
because over the years doing what I do
and talking with the artists uh that I
have like
even when you're making music that isn't
necessarily great I realize that in
order to sort of get the success that
comes with whatever career somebody has
there's a lot of compromises that are
made there's still a lot of effort and
work that you know goes into that behind
the scenes
um and there's still a lot of risks
involved you know like you know being
such a polarizing public figure in a
medium that is as highly contested as
music and put listen putting yourself
out there to the degree that anyone does
is like really and and even like this
with this verse I mean you know for as
funny as it is in a lot of ways like you
can't knock the fact that like logic is
putting himself out there big time and
and on top of it like is logic the only
person that's having these kind of
thoughts specifically in regards to me
probably not there's probably other
artists out there who are like
fantasizing about [__] killing me
when they're watching on YouTube you
know [__] on their records or
whatever but but he's he's the only one
willing to admit it true you have to
like that's true that's a really good
perform Applause for it I totally agree
and by the way he called your fans a
legion of
[__] boy Minion no no what now here's
the thing that that I don't this is the
thing I like least about the verse and
and just and there's a lot of things you
don't like there's a lot of things I
don't like about it I I think logic
frankly frankly is is a little too quick
to sort of like presume a great deal
over even most of the hate that he
receives is like coming specifically
from my fan base so he's he's trying to
do acceptance but he's in a way coping
still a little bit a little bit I I I
think there's a bit of a misfire here
you know frankly especially given that
like you know historically speaking some
of the biggest memes and jokes about him
like for example the biracial stuff I
personally have not endorsed I
repeatedly whenever I see it in like
either chat on Twitch or in multiple
other places I tell them that you know I
say that I don't endorse those jokes I
don't think they're tasteful I don't
think they're good but is that isn't
that just a reference to how much he
talks about it yeah but the thing is at
the end of the day like further pushing
you know into that and sort of just
making fun of him for being biracial or
sort of you know painting him as being
like less hard or lesser relevant or
less interesting as a rapper because
he's biracial it is ridiculous part of
his of his identity his story is
actually crazy yeah I know for sure
because mom was like racist and the Jazz
black yeah no and and I get that I
understand that you know I'm just saying
like personally obviously you and I know
that's like one of the biggest jokes out
there about him and that's not anything
that I've endorsed in my fan base or
like okay you know okay pushed in my fan
base or you know uh uh I guess it uh
encouraged them to engage in uh you know
there's a lot of you know jokes about
him that sort of are far outside of you
know uh my community of people uh you
know who watch my reviews and probably
you know fall in line with a lot of the
opinions that I've given of his music
over the years some positive a lot
negative
um you know and and I would like to
think that my fans would you know be
smart enough to not [__] harass the
guy I don't wish for logic or any artist
that I give a negative review to to be
harassed not any of them I know name one
you hopes gets arrested name one artist
I'm not
I'm not giving the green light to harass
anybody okay all right nice I tried you
did good you passed the test yeah I will
say about Bobby uh logic I went to a
show of his you did yeah I've never seen
him live I went with Mac me and Mac were
hanging out a lot at the time Mac
DeMarco okay I invited us about to come
out and the audience it was at
the Hollywood Bowl he sold that [__]
out of course and the audience was crazy
like they his fans love him they do they
love the inspirational thing they love
everything and they don't mind that it's
that it's like not good music right and
I'm just kidding logic I'm just kidding
you know a lot of people a lot of his
fans do see him as an inspirational
figure and I think he does a lot I think
that's a good thing you know I I like
you know you can give him one thing he
inspires his fans in a positive way big
you know big time it may not be it may
be more with you know his message of
personal struggle more than sort of like
the quality of his art but It ultimately
at the end of the day it's not a bad
thing utilitarian you know speaking in a
utilitarian fashion it's a net positive
definitely I've been to some shows where
like the vibe is like [__] bad it
feels like dangerous being there you
know like bad bad vibes and there it was
just a bunch of really positive young
people that were uh having fun and right
I think that that's something to be
proud of you know right for sure I'm
gonna thank I got to thank my sponsors
here real fast you can sit here you go
to the bathroom that's what I'm doing
yeah okay cool so so do you mind
endorsing uh my products and I'm just
actually I'm gonna go to the bathroom
yeah I'm just kidding I'm gonna go take
a piss
thank you so much to honey yes
we love honey so much you guys
um thank you for supporting us first of
all but honey is such a great wonderful
product
Oh Brother Where would I be without
honey I'd be broke I'd probably be
homeless without honey
thanks to Honey Matt what you don't
think so
no I just realized I put up the uh the
wrong honey we need
this honey join honey dark today show me
the honey bunny show me the honey bunny
oh my God look at those savings yeah so
honey is a free internet plug-in that
automatically scours the internet
to look for the best promo code it's
free it's easy to install
it's a win-win there's really no
drawback to it at all
um and basically what it does you shop
at your favorite websites and I'm
talking fashion Tech food gadgets
gadgets gizmos
um they have it all
basically any major retailer and when
you add your items you go to checkout
you're going to pay
a little button drops down and it says
cert add Coupon boom you click it and
whatever coupon it found that's the
gonna save you the most money
automatically applies here this one was
something Ela bought from this website
that was for buying a rug and without
any preparation without any knowledge
that's a 62 dollar savings I have to
think about it dude you really don't and
that's what I love about honey and
what's actually exciting about honey is
you can use it on your iPhone now too
all you got to do is activate it on
Safari on your phone and save on the
mother loving go
so if you don't already have honey you
are missing out on straight up savings
Anthony fantano endorses and loves honey
until the day he dies I'm just kidding
I'm just kidding I do love savings
I'm just kidding yeah but by getting
yourself uh getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
show which let's be real is more
important than the product itself
right Dan
uh definitely not no
Honey's the most important supporting
our wonderful sponsors yeah yeah yeah
it's a win-win get PayPal honey for free
at joinhoney.com after dark that's join
honey.com afterdark thank you to honey
and please support our sponsors we love
them so much don't we folks
and uh finally thank you to Native for
all my stinky boys and girls out there
you know what Native is Anthony I
actually got a bar of it in oh
endorsement you can't even help it bro
sorry we got that endorsement from the
vegan King bro yeah
yo native this shit's rules man
it's that time of year again
you know yeah where you stink where you
stinking it's time to smell good my New
Year's Revolution resolution
stops thinking you know so when it comes
to personal hygiene
are you really making me read this they
go when it comes to personal hygiene I
knew I had to make a change there I
don't sneak because I use native
products why are y'all putting words in
my mouth
are you okay Army come on
for real that's why I'm using native
personal care products and I do which is
why I don't stink every native product
is thoughtfully formulated to keep you
feeling and smelling fresh all day long
there's actually a few native users in
here yeah I use a deodorant and the body
wash I use the shampoo I love it it's
great for my luscious locks and uh
dude native is taking over yeah you know
why native is taking over why is that
which is the best in the game oh yeah
Nobody Does it I know Anthony certainly
supports that statement
you know I know what it's like to be the
best in the game so right I I I can I
can support them in that thank you I
appreciate that uh send him a check
please native he I'm not giving him a
cut of mine but you guys want to support
him please you know native uh they don't
have aluminum in their deodorant okay
that's it true native keeps their
ingredients to list bare naked the way I
like it with ingredients you understand
that coconut oil shea butter and baking
soda
yeah I like to start my day with just
splashing a whole carton of baking soda
on my genitals just to make sure things
stay fresh down there right Anthony
that's how I like to start the day too
yeah
thank you yeah you know it's absorbs the
smells right yeah
thank you thanks for your backing me up
on that native deodorant checks a lot of
boxes actually 72 hour odor protection
naturally derived ingredients and a
smooth residue-free application one
thing I hate about deodorants when it
leaves all those like chunky [__]
white [__] I'm not down with any of that
business I like the coconut one
oh yeah bro I'm rocking with that one
[__] yeah dude native also offers a
variety of scents including coconut with
new and limited edition since being
released all the time and when you use
native you will smell amazing all day
long thanks to their long lasting scents
do you want to smell spicy and woodsy
or clean and fresh they actually have a
Bo scent
which is kind of kind of intuitive
seriously no oh sorry sorry native not
that I was interested it's a Bo Cent
it's interesting so people don't even
know you're wearing it it's like the new
Rave and natural products
foreign
that's just a joke they don't do that
but they do have a scent for everybody
um
well let's see what else here they've
got candy shop the police what the [__]
is all this [__]
they got a candy shop I love native
because besides the amazing smell
usually my armpits burn from the other
deodorants but this one I think because
it doesn't have the aluminum it burns
what the hell you put on your armpit bro
the other name brands I'm not gonna say
the other name brands but they're losers
the other and it feels great I smell
great God bless the eucalyptus mint
shampoo oh I see it Game Changer man but
here's some gummy bear strawberry
vanilla Taffy sour Berry belt I don't
want my armpits to smell sour
necessarily but I get it
can we hear more about the shampoo since
I don't think you and I could really
attest the quality do you use shampoo or
you just go soap I I can I mention a
rival like a
rivalry
Rivals yeah no no not yet well let's
wait till it's over and we don't believe
in rival soaps here during this read
there's no only one brand it's native uh
now is the time to make the switch from
antiperspirants to Native and when you
visit their site you can discover all
their fresh scents and maybe even try
one out try one of their body washes
while you're at it
feel and smell fresh this year with
Native get 20 off your first order by
going to Native
d-e-o
.com after Dark
or use the promo code after dark at
checkout that's nativedeo.com after dark
links in the description thank you
native so much please for our sponsor
smell like a [__] King bro I probably
shouldn't say [__]
this is after dark can you swear I mean
I can swear but sometimes this they get
mad because when I say [__] and [__]
like that right
but I mean I love their products so
thank you guys peace
we do we have schtick where I
I do yeah
it's not really stick because we get
dropped off yeah it's this great bit
where Ethan ruins every ad it's a great
bit it's funny though they should
appreciate what I do for them
[Music]
so what what should you you should you
go straight soap to the hair or uh I
mean you know it's just my scalp
essentially like to the hair yeah um
yeah I I use uh I I use a Dr Bronner's
the hemp soap you just do the whole
thing everywhere I like I I wash
and then I exfoliate and then I'll wash
again and I just
yeah and and then and then I just come
out clean and the skin is
you know you know that stuff it alarms
me a little bit because it makes you
tingly that's the peppermint one and I
says to myself I don't use that I don't
use okay you don't [__] with the tingles
well the thing is like the peppermint
one is cool but I got a rash off of it
see that and by the way that's why we
don't use that [__] we use native but I
mean we give you [__] rashes there's
like nine other Dr Bronner soaps the
peppermint one is popular because it
people like some people like the tingles
I don't know tingles thinks you think of
like I'm getting cancers I use the
lavender one no tingles okay just smells
like flowers there it is
um I found out about h3h3 thanks to
fantano's Old podcast somebody said so I
did your podcast with it was in uh 2015
2015. that was the first show I ever did
somebody else's show right that's crazy
bro oh yeah I remember this guy Frank JC
thank Jeff c yeah what happened oh yeah
it's probably it's probably uh you could
scroll down I think I moved a lot of
those older podcast episodes yeah
they're gone they're just like nah
they're they're bye-bye that was at a
point where I I think I think like we
were we were on like a a similar plane
with like I was the most famous content
I was Mr Beast of the internet around
that point I was much bigger than you
then I had you on my show then you blew
up seven times and I and I I dropped off
that's not true you're [__] you're Mr
music bro
I'm telling you I was I was good I was
doing Mr BEAST's numbers what year was
that like 100 million per 2015. I was
doing Mr Beast numbers in 2015 but now
I'm just a shell of my former self I see
so it's all been downhill for you it has
what's Frank J C up to is he he was like
a musician right I forget yeah he's he's
a producer I I think he's he's been kind
of playing it sort of low-key lately
okay you know wish him well the internet
is a weird place and has been quite
unfair to him in in some respects well
that's not right yeah but I wish you
well wherever you are my friend there
were there were people uh there were uh
companies that um
sort of went after him for some of his
uh
like production tutorials because I
guess he used like uh oh not legal
version of the software or something and
that's it yeah yeah well he had he had
to take some of his most classic videos
down oh that's very popular but and you
know and we're actually like very good
production tutorials so I I want to hear
I'm just going to a random spot I want
to hear because this is so sweet I'm I'm
[__] I can't do anything to get my
video back in fact you can a dark ass
loser
I'm bitching about I think at the time
there was some drama about Frida or no
not Freedom one of the it was prank
Invasion what was the what was this uh
we listened to some of it yesterday it
was prank invasion was uh coming after
you but they were he was part of a
network that was yeah and he was DMV
Yeah you mentioned soflo as well YouTube
was full of problems back dude it was so
crazy I mean it's full of problems now
but you know it's sort of like a new
host a a new array of shitty problems
but like back then you know you had all
these like
content freedom and usage and fair use
problems and issues that were just like
ridiculous the part that was crazy to me
that they've now resolved
is there was a thing called the content
I I even forgot MCN MCN yeah and you
would do Channel network stuff yeah yeah
and they would [__] everybody thought
they were just straight up lie to you
and say we're gonna earn you more money
yeah you got to join us and we'll do
stuff they don't do they do nothing for
you they take in some cases up to 50 of
your Revenue yeah everybody was part of
them yeah and then the craziest part is
that you couldn't leave yeah they had to
release you now there's a button on your
dashboard you could just bail at any
time but you you would get [__] stuck
and YouTube sends all their money your
money to them right it's crazy yeah no
it's it's true I think a lot of people
unfortunately had to learn the hard way
around that time that like uh
it's it's it's not that much different
than Tick Tock right now because there's
a lot of young content creators on that
platform who are being taken advantage
of by you know either uh networks or by
advertisers uh it's kind of like pushing
them into like these really kind of like
cheap exploitative deals to promote this
promote that promote whatever
um yeah I mean with YouTube at that time
with uh it having you know a
predominantly young audience uh you know
again people had to learn the hard way
in terms of like the contract is the
contract and anything that's being
promised to you over the phone over
email or whatever that is not in writing
is not actually going to be offered yeah
yeah you know that Exchange in terms of
like yeah I'm giving you a 50 of my
revenue for everything that you're
telling me over the phone everything
you've told me over the phone may not
necessarily be in the contract but you
know you're saying it
um but you know what's interesting you
mentioned uh people exploiting people on
Tick Tock I don't know who if you know
this guy Ryan Kavanaugh do you know who
that is I'm maybe I've seen his videos
but I don't know the name yeah no he's
he's an ex movie producer he was the CEO
and owner of Relativity media completely
bankrupted that uh absolutely drove it
into the [__] ground like Gone Gone
got sued and lost a bunch of money crazy
now he he bought trailer
uh which has been a great investment for
him so far and uh he's suing me he's
actually suing me for defamation okay
and um tartius interference which I won
he owes me legal fees on that about
sixty thousand dollars we're waiting he
also sued me for a copyright
infringement and he is just a predatory
[__] monster very ugly is this all
still in progress well so yeah two of
them are still going through the court
can I get in on this can I say something
please defame him it's hard he's
actually a Solo character sometimes
public figures can have such a bad
reputation it's literally impossible to
defame them right and he's one of those
guys like drunk driving he he faked get
bro I'm not even joking you
he went to Habitat for Humanity they had
a whole big party and reception for him
because he was going to donate a million
bucks and he brought a big check and
then he [__] didn't give them [__]
and then after after they threw him this
whole big party on video and [__] he's
like all right I'll give you 35 000 and
that's all he gave him for the million
so he's a [__] monster so again what
you're saying is like there's nothing
that you can say about him that
literally would give him a worse profile
exactly you can't defame him because his
reputation is already uh completely dark
you would have to say something nice
about him and build him up that could be
defamatory then say something bad about
him to sort of knock him back down in
order to do that yeah he's being sued by
a bunch of people he's just like so
shady Ryan Kevin also he said he wants
to [__] a 14 year old Natalie Portman
but anyway moving on inappropriate
relationship with a 40 year old Natalie
Portman that's him uh sorry I do this
segment where I just tell people about
Ryan Kavanaugh he launches a label with
the quad King Bach who is as you know
king bash King Batch as you know is
crushing it maybe he is I don't know I
just haven't seen him in a while Charlie
demilio she's crushing it Bryce Hall is
certainly
he's hungry a hunky guy
and uh Ryan Kavanaugh so he is
moving on to big big things is it is it
defamatory to say he looks like a
douchebag that can is not defamatory
that's opinion but one thing I will
point out that is not defamatory because
his opinion is if you go to the website
it does
or just type Ryan Kavanaugh on Google
actually uh the second result here is a
website called does Ryan Kavanaugh look
like Harvey Weinstein yeah that's our
website okay it's the second result for
his search page and
um if you guys want to visit that
website I'd encourage it you think he
owes me sixty thousand nine hundred
dollars because we won
actually crushed his tortious
interference lawsuit right if you guys
want to go to this website type in Ryan
Cavanaugh into Google go to the search
results click it and spend some time on
it
but you actually what's interesting
about him and I think he'll appreciate
this Anthony as a Critic
right I mean the resemblance is [__]
uncanny what what what
legal
uh
mechanisms are in place to make him pay
you the money that he owes you oh
because he because his his lawsuit was
deemed uh egregious Enough by the judge
that he awarded that he has to pay my
attorney's fees yeah no no I'm saying
like is is there a timeline when he has
to do that oh that's far gone far
expired got it so so what are the
repercussions from considering uh
continuing to see so we need to
basically petition the judge and if
because he's such a uh horrible and
dishonest businessman he owes a lot of
people a lot of money right so we have
to get in a long line but essentially we
can get to the point where the judge can
issue an order that we can like garnish
his wages and take his assets and stuff
like that
so uh I hope you've got a nice car
because I'm [__] coming to repo that
[__] [__]
period but you just think now I
personally would not want a picture of
me kissing Harvey Weinstein on the head
right there they are
uh best friends that's that's that's uh
I've never heard of the I've heard of
you know if you go on Tick Tock or if
you want Instagram right now head
forehead kisses are very popular I've
never heard of the back of the head
kissy he's giving him a sniff on the
head yeah a back of the head kiss
the forehead kiss is one thing he got a
he got DUIs he lied under oath which
that story is crazy is he was accused of
running as a Ponzi scheme of course his
partner later recanted that so it didn't
happen I didn't pay his babysitter he's
threatened critics me specifically sent
me this DM also here's where I
harvesting Brian Cavanaugh is a force of
nature he's a force of nature not the
endorsement I want right but anyway
there it is so you've done nfts I feel
like that would kind of yes he has well
of course they started the divorce they
did true I just I literally just guessed
I just guessed yeah yeah like right up
his alley anybody with that rap sheet
has done nfts yeah and so I don't know
where that came from but I like to just
inform my guess and thank you thank you
for making me more aware of Ryan
Cavanaugh yeah also yeah actually I I
got an email from him he was inviting me
to hang out
and I'm going to just respond and say
hey you know what I'm going to pass on
that oh thanks bro that's and that's it
you know because he's trouble yeah
he's trouble man thanks for keeping on
the right side of the tracks but and I'm
not saying you're into this he does want
he does like people to [__] it his wife
and so he can watch and I'm not that's
not even a joke okay he's got this dude
this Jack Israeli dudes [__] his wife
his name's Brad the bull but we don't
love this love is love
that is a joke by the way and I'm not
making that as effective statement
but uh there's some compelling evidence
anyway moving on
best teeth in the game huh
yes I heard that you got a cavity
recently I did I got cavity last year
let me see the team I've noticed you
have nice teeth good gums really nice
gums what is your brushing uh regimen
your uh rural care twice a day
especially at night and you got a floss
floss and uh mouthwash now do you use
the string or do you use the little
Gadget
um I use the string yeah yeah I don't
use the gadget the gadget is [__]
horrible and sure for the environment
but I love it yeah it's so good you know
I I like I like the motion of the string
I like the you I get off on the motion I
think it's fun yeah this is our
thumbnail by the way I don't know if you
know because I just want to tell you I
actually don't have any cavities uh [__]
none zero look at this
wow I'm jealous let me see your mouth
let me see your back to back where's
your cavity
um it's it was it's actually kind of a
funny thing it's in between two teeth oh
so it's not between two people it's not
visible but with so much but what was so
messed up about it is that they needed
to
like sort of like wear down the inside
like the inner part of two teeth next to
each other to get to it to fill the
cavity and so now there's almost like a
gap on the inside of the two teeth that
have the cavity between them now which
I'm always having to sort of like chew
around you might say that your teeth
have a blemish yeah they do yeah most
definitely I [__] up because people
call me the hairline King and so I don't
know two kings coming together your
hairline's doing better than mine so
well you're downplaying it my hairline
is insane
it's the best in the game yeah I mean
well I'm saying I'm not competing here
I'm not competing in terms of in terms
of hairline and and Cavities I mean
you're you're you're you're killing me
here but your teeth this is why you
brought me here today I know I came back
no but your friend your teeth have a
presence they're bit they're beautiful
they have a good shape yeah yeah good
shape yeah it's good shape the gums are
incredible you do anything for the gum
carrot they're very pink well I mean you
know this flossing is also Gum Care it
helps prevent okay okay I don't know if
you know I was number one on Wiki feet
too for a while until they they my my
feet are terrible my feet are you did
you see my feet in the human cake video
yeah oh it's been a while yeah oh that's
one speak actually that's a question I
wanted to ask you that's an interesting
one filthy Frank of course who is mutual
friends of both of ours right
I don't know if he was in that video but
obviously the human cake yeah yeah he
was okay that was a long time ago it was
a long time ago but who would have
thought that
filthy Frank
the most
I mean how do you even just would become
one of the most relevant pop artists
he's really popping yeah and good yeah
no for sure what are your thoughts on
joji I mean I generally think his music
has a powerful presence to it I think
his latest project he kind of phoned it
in I don't I don't know what it maybe it
was a contractual obligation thing it
was almost like a an EP with some bonus
tracks on it sort of like being marketed
as an album but you know every once in a
while you know like brockhampton for
example you know they had to end out
their contractual obligations with a few
records before they ended the band and
you know the two records they just came
out with didn't really sound like they
had a whole lot I ever put into them
um you know kind of the same thing with
the joji record but there were some
tracks off of a like glimpse of us which
are really good
um I I think he's coming into his own as
a songwriter and a singer and it's been
really cool to kind of see him go into a
different creative Avenue yeah it's
really interesting his music videos are
awesome love also also you you [__] with
Matt Watson
uh I don't like him no no no but I like
I mean I like he sent me I don't know
he's kind of a piece of [__] they sent
me a chair that was really small uh from
what I've heard I don't like I'll say
I'll I'll say I'm on good terms with
Matt but he's also kind of you know
making his attempt at a little YouTuber
kind of music balancing thing too and um
you know I I think it's it's it's good
that people in this field are
um doing doing making some waves in the
music world yeah I don't know if you've
seen this
this is all I know about Matt Watson is
this right here
ready Matt
did you by the way I'm joking by the way
but did you see Joe Rogan crying about
how this clip you didn't saw that bro no
what did you say You're Gonna Love this
oh my God I got it here someone send
this to me
dude you're gonna love this so you you
watch this you you saw that I did watch
this and I'm aware of that like you know
I I come from an era of YouTube I
remember Dad yeah me too me too you know
honestly like truth be told I would not
want to [__] with Dad like Dad I was
knocking in the ring with Dad knowing
his even at the weight that I am knowing
his background he's he's gonna out he's
he's faster than you you can't keep up
with that speed he's a dancer he's gonna
have he's gonna hurt he's endless sane
yeah yeah like he came on our show to
promote uh his fight against Matt and he
was just like um
he's an animal my life is a tragedy I'm
fighting for my dead girlfriend I was
like whoa dude I want to [__] I don't
[__] yeah you don't want to you don't
want a dead girlfriend punch no no no he
wants a dead girlfriend punched to the
face no but I would pity anyone who gets
in the ring with him dude that would be
a [__] disaster for anybody
yeah but anyway no I like Matt Watson
he's just a giant [__] dude yeah he
didn't prep for this he didn't practice
at all very obviously like geez the body
blows like he's punching so fast dude
you can't even keep up bam Bama lamb
this was this this was the first fight
and I was just like what is he's not
he's not even he's not defending he's
not even really trying to hit back oh
what do you what okay what is this how
his his uh comb over blowing in the wind
right because he's so fast yeah so
anyway everybody's familiar with this so
Joe Rogan somehow came across this fight
and I why is he wearing a NASA yeah like
what yeah is is Joe okay I don't think
so I mean the man does a lot of DMT and
at that age I'm just not sure that the
chemistry of the brain he he's he's
wearing a a fake cosplay Master top like
he's six years old I mean like does he
think he's actually an astronaut he
might I mean he spends his free time in
a deprivation take on DMT that cannot be
good for your brain he thinks he's
orbiting the moon right now well you'll
see how [__] up he is so he saw that
fight between dad and Matt Watson and I
just need to emphasize you that this his
take right now is 100 genuine [__] you
this is a video of a boxing match
between a father and a son
it made me so sad I swear to God made me
so sad oh my God because it's just young
the greatest he looks like he's probably
like 17 or 18. no and the father's 42.
no and the father beats the [__] out of
him no I mean like no he literally has
Daddy on his chest
that's your son well no and we're
watching you no you're done because I
get your son probably got cocky with you
but and he celebrates after he knocks
his son out it made me so sad
because first of all I'm like that kid
has brain damage now I'm 100 maybe it's
just a little maybe it'll be fine maybe
he'll get over it but maybe you [__]
him up that can happen too he might be
depressed from now on after that he
might [__] up his pituitary gland it
happens to people and you just did that
to your son you're supposed to like
touch him up you're supposed to not even
hurt him like slam him in the body a
little bit like you think he can fight
okay good dude okay let's have a little
boxing match you don't tee off on your
son's face on television it's crazy
how was how old was the kid kid looks
young to me he looks like you know he
could be 20. he could be 19. he looks
young he's real skinny and the father's
kind of jacked not too jacked but you
know he's fit and he could [__] punch
he knows how to box and the sun doesn't
look like he has any idea what the [__]
he's doing
I don't know what the thing was that's
really what he's reacting to I saw it
yes yeah we know this for a fact you'll
see you'll see you'll see you guys are
crazy
that you failed you've failed as a man
yeah this is it that's not exactly no
it's not what is it they're not father
son oh why does it lie it says father
knocks out something celebrity
YouTuber thing this guy's a YouTuber and
he's a YouTuber I'm such a sucker can
you [__] believe Christ oh my [__]
god regular Entertainer in the world and
he's informing a whole generation of
young men also on top of it it's like
you you literally make your bread and
butter off of
like a sport where people like if if
he's that upset about people getting
their pituitary glands [__] up
like in in your field people get their
pituitary glands [__] up all the time
what does it matter if it's between a
father and son you know it's like if if
it's not between a father and son are
you less sympathetic to the pituitary
gland obviously yeah yeah but as long as
it's not between a father and son [__]
up as many pituitary glands as you want
you know he's just so unstable he's like
I was sitting there and I was close
[__] up yeah bro no your personal
experience I was thinking about it I was
in the deprivation tank this morning
thinking about this video
I was just coming down for my DMT trip I
had tears come rolling down my face
[Music]
why would a father do this to his son
the pituitary gland is not self-healing
I don't think I don't think it is
hold on I need to
I need to hit the DMT pipe one more time
I'm gonna Google if you can heal your
pituitary gland yeah let's get some
details on the pituitary
that's him exercising
yeah he's such a [__] Meathead bozo
foreign
also I love how he goes why do they lie
you dumb idiot [__] ugh I'd love that
for him anyway I'm surprised you haven't
seen that book well I mean glad I could
show it to you good good news for
anybody with a [__] up pituitary gland
there are options okay treatable surgery
there is also hormone therapy okay
there's also radiation therapy
if you're pituitary's [__] up
radiation how's that going to help
anyone oh I mean I I can't tell you I'm
no expert I'm just Dr Google over here
but um you know seems like seems like
Joe's a little out of the know when it
comes to it has options yeah Matt has
options if it's pituitaries [__] up
which if it continues to be he could go
down that Joe Rogan route he could
become the next 100 who probably also
has his pituitary gland [__] up right
interesting all right check it out we've
got a bunch of like kind of games and
Goofs we got you said you have to leave
at 3 30. yeah okay so let's we got all
kinds of fun Goofs here so
okay let me go I mean I don't the beef
with Drake I'm sure you've talked a lot
about it
um I did want to touch on that and then
we'll get into the games I guess okay
so is it I mean Drake's been thinking
about you now you're not a drake fan
this is the lore going there's some
records I'm a fan of there are a lot of
songs I'm a fan of he's got great things
yeah the the number of people who I'm a
fan of it's very few and far between
okay off often often when it comes to a
lot of the modern artists I review I
can't afford to be a fan of anybody
because once you're once you're that you
know you you you can't uh
you can't record you can't you can't
review someone's music in an unbiased
Manner and I have to save my biases for
white power music I see that I have to I
have to hate on white power music I
can't just you know blindly hate other
music I need to save that for any music
uh made by people who are pro-white okay
that's fair so the the story is you made
a video right saying that Drake slid
into your DMs and this is all fabricated
the fact that he slid into my DMs was
true the DN right you showed were
fabricated okay so he slid okay hold on
you thought you were the only goofster
all right hold on I'm a goofster too
um I got some goofs
hold on hold on I want to find the
original
find the original one the one that he
actually sent you yeah the one that he
actually sent me that he shared here it
is here's his Instagram story so Drake
actually dm'd you this right he actually
DM me that he says your existence is a
light one yeah and the one is because
you are alive now if he doesn't like me
wouldn't wouldn't the wouldn't me being
alive be a detriment to my score
wouldn't he be less generous because I
guess I guess to him a one is like you
know wouldn't I be it wouldn't I be a 10
if I if I was dead potentially uh that
could that could change things yeah he
says and somehow wife the black girl
right
so he's actually deep into your life
he's like I don't think he's Googling my
personal information I don't think most
of your fans are aware of the you know
ethnicity of your wife right because
you're very private right but he does
know that yeah he's weird and he knows
your Cadence he speaks like you he's
using my scoring system and he's I'm
feeling a light to decent which is kind
of what you say right one on your
existence so right this is like he's mad
he's like salty yeah
so kind of so what do you what's going
through your marketing and I left him on
red ah
he was expecting you to try to
so what do you think I mean this is like
this must have been so unexpected yeah
when I got this this was like
um this was uh uh like midnight this he
must be on West Coast time this was like
midnight on a Wednesday and I was
working out of my garage and I just you
know I was looking at my Instagram and I
saw that I had a message from him and um
you know I just I screenshotted and I
sent to a bunch of my friends who were
just like this is not real this cannot
no this is not you you made this up and
I was like no I sent it to maybe like
half a dozen people I was like look at
this he says well what the [__] should I
do and um you know I just sat there and
I thought about it and um you know I
thought about the morals of the
situation obviously you don't just want
to share private DMS to the internet
that's that's bad form personally in
this situation I wouldn't mind because
like he's he's sending you an
unsolicited hate he is but
simultaneously it's like I also thought
in my head that's what he would want you
know yeah and and I think like given his
profile and given my profile there would
have very much been sort of like the
inevitable reaction of like this is fake
you made nobody no no way Drake messaged
this to you yeah you know so because
that was sort of the presumption I I got
what you probably get a lot of the time
I got content brain so you know
something happens to you and immediately
you're like how do I turn this into
content sure so I was like since people
are gonna think the message from him is
made up anyway
let's just make one up and then and
since and since he watches he'll see a
video that says Drake dm'd me and he'll
watch it and he'll see it's a funny
inside joke so so [__] brilliant
because
you were right that he expected you to
share it and I think his idea was like
oh nobody's going to believe him
or you baited him so good or either
either not believe me or he'll see me on
camera mad oh you called me a light one
right you know
um see me angry or see me like you know
uh firing shots at him or being bitter
or whatever and I thought that like I
thought honestly even though Drake does
have a reputation for being a little
bitter and you know sort of vindictive
sometimes I thought he would see the
video and think it's funny right and
then maybe DM me and just be like that
was pretty funny I thought you were
going to talk about the DM that I sent
you but instead you did the silly thing
that's pretty cool I thought he would
maybe want to chat after that and just
kind of be friendly or just you know see
see that there was no malice coming from
my end because obviously I don't spend
the video attacking him no you know I I
I I didn't I didn't necessarily expect
him to do what he did dude this was one
of my favorite stories of the year and
what I loved about this is because when
I watched your video the first time I
was like Drake seems [__] awesome
like this DM rules I was like yo Drake
is kind of like super cool he's a nice
guy so you you fabricated this DM
exchange you said make it seem nice dude
I was a huge Drizzy fan after this he
says Anthony it's Drizzy I know we don't
see eye to eye about music and that
you're not the biggest fan of mine
thanks for the kind words on take care
and if you're reading this though but it
is what it is you know can always hope
you'll like the next one but I'm not
smiley smiley yeah yeah
but I'm not messaging you about your
video I'm actually messaging you because
I found a really great vegan cookie
recipe that I love you to try wait hold
on I have to find in my bookmark here it
is
I'd really appreciate if you could give
this a spin and let me know if it's
worth trying myself appreciate you
Drizzy out so people have made the
recipe on Tick Tock and it looks like it
came out pretty good did you just find
this on the internet and copy paste my
editor did they I I had I had the idea
and I said like I I it was it was sort
of a Choose Your Own Adventure thing I
said to them
um shout out to Austin I said to them
um we can either do a cookie recipe as a
fake DM or we could do Drake messaging
me to ask about like what can he say to
this girl that he has a crush on and
then I give him advice on like what to
say to the girl
um and and Austin went to no we got to
go cookie recipe okay uh you know just I
I said I screenshotted the DMS and I
said use this as a base for the
Photoshop and just throw the throw the
recipe in there and um uh you know
whatever you find on the internet and
that's how that came together and so you
put this video and I'm sure all your
fans just thought it was some kind of
wacky yeah they just thought it was some
silly stuff because on the fantano
channel I'm you know I I very often will
[__] post or just sort of like you know
give very inauthentic or sort of silly
opinions on things just sort of like
throw people off there's a lot of
serious opinions on the fantano channel
too and commentary but uh every once in
a while I'll do a silly video just to
you know kind of uh be tongue-in-cheek
or be you know whatever and So within
two hours Drake who is apparently
a huge fan of yours right
um
posted this story
which presumably he was like no this is
what I said to him yeah that's really
what happened kind of like
outed himself as kind of a big dummy
because
this makes him look like such a [__]
douche
and gives you a ton of clout so in terms
of Chess I mean I I appreciate it you
know I mean thank you at the end of the
day and you know I I don't have to like
you know uh get into this for like clout
reasons or anything like that but uh you
know since then we we've had we've had
positive exchanges you've spoken to
Drake since then we we've I'll say we
have we've had positive exchanges you
know not not to the level of logic we're
not like on the phone besties and you
guys dm'd uh we we've we've had exchange
you don't want to say you don't I don't
want to say but it's been positive okay
you know it's like there's no there's no
there's no bad blood there okay that's
nice no animosity that's nice I'd love
to hear that yeah
he's probably feeling bad because you
just [__] clowned on him so bad like
this this YouTube music reviewer got the
best of drake drake drake drake drake
drake drake
so well there you go oh by the way and
the best part I mean how many followers
he's got 119 million followers he
basically promote you to you have 500
000 I mean what a l yeah I got like I
think I got like 20K new followers that
day that's awesome just off him sharing
that it was Preposterous well there it
is
um
by the way you called him a groomer I
don't know if you guys have discussed
that on in the DM that was that was not
a uh a part of the discussion it says oh
wait what is this
no that was that's somebody else's you
retweeted this uh that was just that was
just a funny meme I didn't know I I
don't recall the groomer oh here yeah
it's just this far yeah that's that's
just that part do you think he's a
groomer that we're talking about the
Millie Bobby Brown thing or him dating
like his knee or what was it I I girl
like he has he has a history of having
some contact with teenagers that people
seem to be kind of I don't know
I guess uh uncomfortable yeah it's a
little it's a little odd it's a little
weird I mean I I guess I'll say this
like if
Drake is such a you know uh I mean I
guess in the in the wake of me too we've
seen all types of people you know um
Fall From Grace because of their very
you know bad behavior and rightfully so
um you know I guess I would like to
think that
if there was anything super scandalous
out there about him like you know if he
was stupid enough to send
underage girls DMS that could
potentially incriminate him you know
maybe it would have come out by now
that's a fair assumption you know
I guess so you never know you know then
and that's the thing you never really
know and I don't want to make any
presumptions of the guy or say anything
uh defamatory or something like that but
I think um you know sort of like go off
the presumption that he is most
definitely you know oh sorry no no he's
not that was a joke there's no evidence
that that anything like that happens
purely Joe not but I mean but obviously
again it's like it's it's obviously
widely acknowledged and understood and
you know even guys like Tyler the
Creator have sort of like you know
thrown out like a sub in a song like oh
Drake I have a milli for you or whatever
you know a million or a you know so on
and so forth so I mean you know I think
uh I I think it's something that I hope
that he in his career you know continues
to distance himself from and just you
know behaves but simultaneously I don't
know what you know was sort of like
going on in his head
um with the new record that he just put
out with 21 Savage in terms of like the
shots at Megan uh which obviously Tori
did not age well that did nature that
didn't age well and then he had um
uh you know the shots uh against what
was it Serena
uh that he was I'm trying to remember
like her significant other because Drake
had gone on a couple dates with her at
one point
um and uh you know which I think would
have made for an interesting couple I
mean you know Drake and a tennis
champion uh together but uh you know I
guess he sort of threw some shots at her
significant other and you know maybe
sort of like the bitter X in that
situation I don't know but you know
either way bad looks I don't know
yeah so you know what I mean Drake uh
just [__] chill bro why is this
Ohanian on how to pronounce it he's like
one of the co-founders of Reddit right
yeah yeah Serena Williams husband
actually connected with him once I don't
remember for what
but yeah he's a you know he's super
successful he should just enjoy his
success exactly why you got to be so
pressed bro you went from being a
character in a wheelchair I mean
nothing's wrong with that it's just
funny image he's an actor yeah for being
an actor on You Know Drama show to being
bitter about you know uh various sending
you hate DMS and sending uh music
reviewers hate DMs
as you know and like God bless uh all of
our
um all of our fans who are in
wheelchairs but uh this is a funny image
let's not pretend like it's not right
can we not pretend
I'm gonna get this tattooed on my chest
bro
that'd be a statement
anyway let's get on to the game so uh
thank you for the uh
thank you for the Drake Lord yeah no
problem all right we have a bunch of
meme songs we want you to review okay on
this show we have a lot of goofy kind of
unbelievable songs that we keep playing
yeah we've got like some good running
gags we've got five here okay I'm gonna
play them for you and just on be honest
okay yeah and ready for full honesty
yeah I know you always are radical
honesty now this one comes from R Kelly
who's you know a great singer oh Jesus
Christ uh are you familiar with this
tune
play it up so this is uh called
passports he is on tour in Ethiopia uh
here you go
on a plane to come out here
me and my girl broke up
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah we broke up
ladies are excited about that oh yeah
the beat is I'm feeling it too right
it's too Melanie
and it was over something really really
silly yeah something we shouldn't have
broken up over
but it is it is what it is we broke up
and here I am
tonight
he's in jail of course
sex trafficking and throwing
imprisonment
[Music]
[Applause]
that broke up with a man and they
looking for somebody else right now
[Music]
shout out to the Ethiopian TV channel on
YouTube
good angles where else would we see this
single ladies put your hands yeah this
is a deep cut right
shout out to the keyboard player too I
think we singly blew this song up but
hold on the best part
[Music]
now I would like to get to know you and
talk to you
have a drink or something and we can
just have something to eat and just
but at the end of the conversation
at the end of the conversation I'm gonna
want you to come back to America with me
I know I am
so you got to be willing
to split the difference come to America
and see me I come out here to see you
Ethiopia
[Music]
but it's so hard to get back and forth
so hard to get back and forth problem
how am I gonna get you
from Ethiopia
to America right
let me think let me think he has a
solution it's coming
you haven't seen this oh my God I'm so
excited
[Music]
Yeah
well yeah it's a big problem I got it
he's got it do you have your passport
did you get your shots girl would you
like to come back we'd love to America
[Music]
wow girl would you like to come back
and again he was arrested foreign
[Music]
come back
I Wanna Know
[Music]
so I [__] love this song I'm
was this rehearsed I guess that's a
hotly debated yeah now in my opinion I
think he took the show on the road these
guys think it was improvised but it
could just improvised for that date
specifically that's what that's what a
lot of people think but to me it's like
he's put a lot of that time he knows
about the immigration process you put
the time into it he knows about the
shots you you think he's going from
country to Country and swapping out the
the you know whatever Place whatever
location that he's in and sort of
offering an American trip to you know I
think Ethiopia potentially Zambia
Germany wherever I think probably he
preys on more of the poor African
countries I think sure I mean anybody
who he can sort of Lord over yeah this
was one of our top selling merch items
of last year by the way
um
you know my uh my my opinion my expert
opinion is I I feel like the the musics
about at an eight but the lyrics are are
at a not good so I'm kind of torn well
we need to we need a rating so we're I I
would say we're Landing at about maybe a
decent three maybe a three yeah so so
you're saying a lot the melody is nice
the melody in the music and the drummer
was killing it background singer was on
point as well right who may have been
trafficked from whatever country they
were at previously right right right
that that background singer maybe sort
of saying does anybody want to join my
band tonight
right you become a member of the band
yes as soon as you you join up so um but
the lyrics is it what is it that what
he's saying because his singing is
beautiful right is it the content
content of what's very creepy content
okay okay so that that that yeah okay a
three yeah I would give it a now I am
now critic I will give this a seven but
uh I'm no critic I love this song again
but okay I'm glad that you saw that
here's another one this one comes from
uh Logan Paul had a crypto project last
year yeah I heard about that dink doink
it's it's gone really well right well so
no there's one there there's a new one
that he's getting [__] about the coffee
Zilla yeah but this was from last year
it was a crypto project called dink
doink is anybody in does anybody have
any Logan Paul nfts that works on your
production crew I wish man right is that
is that a sponsor they'd be they'd be
retired by now is that a sponsor Logan
Paul well what's interesting and you
know everybody put their money in to
this dink dink and then all of a sudden
it just went to zero like oh really
crazy that's never happened
before but anyway here he made this
theme song for The dink doink coin and
I'd like you to view it
[Music]
it's not even a cent oh no well well
here would be a scent it's a free yeah
it's a fraction
for the chart you should go to the uh
the max hit Max at the top right so here
is the history of Ding Dong coin
um so it was never even a cent to begin
with
well you know what a lot of cryptos
because he they make like a hundred
trillion right so
um
it's still a lot of money I think and so
they do these weird things but yeah it's
down to oh it's weird
yeah so here here it here it is uh sorry
to interrupt you there who decided on
the South Park aesthetic Logan Paul as
far as I am aware is The Mastermind
behind this project got it yeah he's
just a big fan of South Park
I want you to think on my face take a
drink on my chest yeah yeah ding dong
you're my favorite coin why don't you
come on over they should sue himself I I
honestly
honestly to God looks like a South Park
you know that's an interesting legal
issue like because he's they're not
using the characters but they are using
the art stuff I wonder if that is it's
like artistic it's like artistically
speaking a deep fake like what if
somebody used a deepake of you to
endorse that's a really that's a really
really good point yeah like the way that
it looks it looks like Matt and Trey
made a video to get people to buy up
into an nft scan that's a really good
point and I and I don't think it's too
late for them to sue to them too either
maybe if they are watching this making a
recommendation for yeah this is not
legal advice
this is legal advice two of them
why don't you come on over take pictures
of my feet yeah yeah think don't think
you're my favorite even the humor style
[Music]
you know what here I think Matt and Trey
Parker were involved in this project I'm
just saying that because it makes his
defamation because like I'm not involved
so if he if we can show that he
convinced people that South Park is
involved you can show then you can show
you can show it here you can show this
in court Matt and Trey yo South Park is
involved in this token I'm gonna buy it
because I trust them
so that could be useful in court
[Music]
and yet the numbers never went High
never never they just went down no maybe
maybe after this it went higher but yeah
mostly
[Music]
by the way this is actually the
thumbnail yeah but the shiny ass teeth
um
what do you think I can't believe you
didn't make my teeth like [__] up in
the you should have thought I didn't
want to do that I thought about it I
can't to be honest I always thought
about it actually actually I like
um jeez uh it's kind of a fire beat I
think yeah it's kind of a fire beat and
ding dong it's my favorite kind patchy
you know again I feel like I'm feeling
about maybe a seven on the music but
then you know had like a nice emo trap
kind of vibe to it going on but but then
you had kind of the scamminess of yeah
listen I'm gonna I give this a point
zero zero zero zero zero zero one seven
four three one out of ten wow
there it is to the Moon with this rating
yeah
once again music is good the content
questionable yeah wow okay interesting
so the meme songs are having a rough
time here today but this one I think the
content is good okay there's nothing
wrong this one is a iconic song it's
called that's America to me okay and I
think I do love some blind patriotism
you're gonna love this one
sorry I'm going to start up from the top
here of course
you want the tension to build to build
on the intro yeah it's all good
it's America to me is that how it goes
exactly okay you're right nailed it I've
never heard this before I was like never
[__] heard this I was like have you
heard this nope
mom and dad and apple sorry there's just
some comments I need to read uh I see a
lot of people saying this new South Park
nft seems really interesting so South
Park it made an nft called dink doink
did you all hear about it hmm I just
want to get him soon so that sounds like
something that sounds out of character
for them but but there it is it's this
unmistakably South Park nft
maybe they can still invest
mom and dad and apple pie baseball games
and picnics in July some of the guy's
mustache is good
[Music]
even that dude's mustache has molester
kids
[Music]
[Applause]
I did mail it how did I know how did I
[__] know I legit was how did I know
and
choreography right
there's a budget too in this I don't
know
defensive rights
[Music]
yeah that's that's what they teach
American foot soldiers
because it's got so much
he says Atlanta diversity but I don't
see one I see everybody on that stage of
the way it's [__] oh never mind [__]
me in the ass there this is diversity
respect for him throughout our history
as long as you respect God
[Music]
[Applause]
that's America
that's America to me
[Applause]
[Music]
so so I mean wholesome top subject
matter yeah beautiful singing voice top
10 choreography 10 out of 10. it's a 10
out of 10. come on be honest Flawless
this isn't a joke it's flawless
it's Flawless so you're giving this a
perfect time yeah giving it a perfect as
far as singles go how many tens have you
handed out uh as far as singles I don't
know I haven't really I don't really
score a whole lot of singles this is
this is the rare occasion which I've
scored a single
okay so America's leading the way we
have two more I want to show you Andrew
Tate of course I'm sure you're aware did
you know he had a short music career
yeah we uh did a fantana channel
reaction to it is this Mr Plenty or is
this the other daddy oh sugar okay no I
haven't done a reaction to sugar daddy
yet I think sugar daddy he made private
shortly after or something I need to he
privated why would he do that
yeah why would he Pride at this
I might I might do I might do a fun
little follow-up yeah you should because
the first the first video did so well so
so I got content brain yeah yeah no
absolutely you're going to want to watch
this yeah
girl you look good I don't want to lie
I don't want to try I'll take you to
Dubai put you in the sky
nice
[Music]
call me Mr plenty check the leather on
the Bentleys
it's rare it's really long like I mean
three minutes what's what I find weird
about this video what I find weird about
this video is that often in rap videos
you will have a handful of different
shots and across those shots you will
have a costume change because obviously
like you have a rapper that wants to
like you know they want to showcase
their outfits and their chains and you
know their style and so on and so forth
Andrew Tate has gone from one haircut to
another is that he has like this weird
little short like English bug yes and
then he goes full bald and he's kind of
bouncing back and forth between being
bald and that is very interesting that's
the game so here he's full bald yeah
sometimes he's full bald then sometimes
he got a little like and sometimes he
got a little on the top yeah which I
don't get it's kind of jarring and this
guy has a shirt as a dress so what do we
what are we feeling in terms of uh the
musical credentials here yeah this this
is this is mid the beat sucks
the vocals are the flow the flow there's
not a lot of flow to it a bit of a color
Mr plenty oh wait there's I'll put you
in my Bentley wait the best part is here
apparently at 1 30. let me make sure you
see that to give it a fair review
[Music]
yeah we we play that sound bite alone
that was kind of fresh such a smooth
voice such a smooth beautiful it's me at
ease yeah it makes me want to be sex
trafficked yeah
he he does he does if somebody said to
me
what does a sex trafficker sound like
rapping on a beat it probably would be
like
your girl with your girl moved to
Romania I'll take good care of you it
would be somewhere in that bad cigarette
breath range yeah
so what are we feeling I I would say
we're feeling it
a negative three okay okay all right or
whatever whatever amount of
whatever amount of years Andrew Tate's
going in The Slammer out of 10.
that'd be a really good he hasn't been
sentenced yet I think he's going to be
doing at least 15 in my opinion
damn I wanted to play you this Yoko Ono
song but it got claimed oh that sucks
I've never seen this notification though
it says the owner allows the content to
be used on YouTube oh so is it still
monetized
I'm kind of a Yoko Stan okay
let's pull it maybe maybe just open it
on the phone and he can listen to it
because you all know the war what's
what's the song The War Zone war zone
yeah is it like a race is it like a
recent one
um it's not super old it's within the
past seven years yeah okay yeah it's
probably okay show me this awful ass
song should we just let's just listen to
it I guess for a moment yeah yeah yeah
do it I want to hear it yeah
I can find you a good time stamps before
the owner allows content to be used on
YouTube
see the click the details what does it
say and I've never seen that either oh
let's see
can I play a Yoko Banger I'd love I love
you
it's your call
okay uh it says impact on the video no
impact no impact Channel not affected
visibility and monetization
um this channel I uploaded doesn't have
my position so I can't check that
okay well are we gonna hear it
um I thought are you gonna play one do
you do you want do you do you want to
search it up here do you want me to play
it off my phone
it's called walking on thin ice oh
wait you want me to search it okay sorry
yeah because it's gonna get claimed too
I think okay well we don't have to do it
that's what I'm afraid you know it's
like yeah I'll just play it I'll just
play it over my phone yeah
High budget yeah 13 000 views after six
years John's Market it's a deep cut
it's got a great it's got a great dance
beat oh there was like a rogue frame in
there they didn't even edit it up right
like look at this there's like a rogue
frame there you see that oh that's weird
it's like Fight Club right
maybe that was that was the point of
inspiration this song is a lot better
than the one oh I believe it this one's
a bot all right here let me play you um
war zone play foreign
elephant noises foreign
it's got almost half a million views on
it well it's I think we're responsible
for that okay
maybe a little on the nose
but the machine gun sounds are so bad
oh [__] this song's awesome
John they're balls
[Music]
oh right
if one of you upload it to a monetized
channel real fast
can play it
yeah it's that it's that for the whole
time I mean frankly I I find her voice
haunting I've always found her voice
very like in a compelling way like in in
an interesting way in an interesting way
well for War Zone off of what I heard
we'll uh well we could we could say a
seven out of ten for Warzone wow it
would be it would be a 10 if there was
actual machine gun fire in the studio
okay as opposed to as opposed to
something yeah we we need actual gunfire
in the studio
Zach you're [__] crazy dude that's
Wendy Williams if she was if she was
singing like that while firing a Glock
okay in the studio that'd be I think
that would be that would really bring
the vibe of a war zone home well John
Lennon's uh Legacy is in good hands
there
do you fan of John Lennon uh I like John
Lennon's stuff um I've uh uh interviewed
his uh sunshine on the show okay well
okay nice was that the one he abandoned
or the one he loved
that was uh that was that was that was
the one between him and Yoko that he
loved okay yeah that must be nice
all right so um let me um this is a lot
I know you said it's 3 30. so I'm gonna
do this really fast yeah do you need to
leave right now yeah go for no tell me
okay so we all put together we're
confessing our guilty music Pleasures
okay and I'll just be fast I'll tell you
what it is and you just give me your
snap all right judgment my guilty music
pleasure is Third Eye Blind I [__] with
them hard bro
um actually the debut is really good
debut album is insane right gotta get my
punk ass off the streets
there's bangers on the debut so that's
uh fantano approved yeah the debut is
fantastic okay okay hell yeah dude hell
yeah all right Zach's guilty music
pleasure is Creed yeah that's I'm I
can't you can't get behind though what's
wrong dude what why just any kind of
singing from the 90s or early 2000s
that's just basically a shitty Eddie
Vedder ripoff
you gotta admit though
not from a singing standpoint but the
choruses and it's the hooks are I don't
have to admit anything I'm not admitting
anything you have to admit support on
this one Zach so you don't like the soul
patch singing no okay do you does Eddie
Vedder get a pass no I don't know you
don't even know I barely [__] with Pearl
Jam wow so so he's really out on this
I'm I like when it comes to that era
it's more it's Smashing Pumpkins it's
Nirvana it's um yeah I I would say Chris
Cornell hits more in that realm but I
actually like Chris's singing yeah as
far as that soul patch singing I like
Chris Cornell Zach or Dan you're like my
children I just cycled through three
years it's a brand of Breads
and then I notice your enthusiasm at uh
fantano's denouncing of
pearl of Pearl Jam yeah I I've always
been a Pearl Jam hater
um just that one frankly is yeah I'm not
into in that style of singing and
Nirvana you're gonna just you are you
gonna say listen I I respect Nirvana but
um [__] what's your fave what's what
what what's your error of that Arrow
Creed not not of that era but like what
what is what do you like what is your
favorite personal era or Vibe if like
you just don't [__] with that yeah he's
grunge era at all uh I've always been
more on the punk side of things okay um
so the stuff that was going on one of my
favorite uh bands fugazi in the early
90s I think about that out of all the
records that I have that's one of the
bands that I have the most records of so
ugazi yeah oh so he has three
credibility that's uh for guys who's
great but maybe a little bit minded
Three band I mean you know I didn't like
Nirvana I mean yeah I feel like you
should like Nirvana yeah what's wrong I
don't dislike Nirvana I just am not
they're not that important to me
personally you know it it I never had an
era where like that music really meant a
lot to me or anything so it's just it's
just always been like Radio Rock to me I
don't know I got it oh God which which
like in in some ways it is but isn't
necessarily a bad thing in my view
no again I'm not trying to [__] on
Nirvana all right well Dan let's do your
guilty pleasure since you're since we're
yeah right after saying that I'm gonna
be so embarrassed now listen Dan's
guilty pleasure I'll just be straight up
I didn't even know this was embarrassing
because I'm a huge fan of this band and
everybody I know growing up is so I'm
just gonna blurt it out maybe it's a
California thing Sublime
I've actually been on a Sublime kick
lately there we go this past this past
summer I I
sublime's great this past summer Ice uh
my my cousin hit me up like this again
this is this was like obviously vaccines
are out and people are getting out into
the world a little bit more weather's
warming up and my cousin hit me up out
of nowhere and was just like hey are you
free this weekend me and my boyfriend
are going to a concert do you want to
come with and I was like what's the
concert and the concert was this band
that's like pretty notorious for being a
Sublime cover band that tours all over
the east coast and I've been I've been
basically avoiding them since College
like so they do have a cringy reputation
yeah they've been around I mean among
music nerds yeah you know so it's like
they've been playing venues pretty
regularly since like you know 20 years
ago not the cover band but like the
original band oh um I I would say among
music nerds Sublime isn't taking all
that serious okay no they're not and
yeah I went out to go see him live and I
mean it was it was fun you know and and
everybody was having a great time and
um yeah I remember a lot of their songs
from the radio when I was a kid you know
I they were like they were in the air
they were all over the place and um you
know I think uh some of the content of
their music in terms of like you know
the appropriation aspects have has like
aged very badly frankly but there's
still like some good songwriting there
okay there it is not too embarrassing
there for you Dan yeah it's some pretty
decent white boy reggae
um right the only total denounciation so
far is for Zach with Creed right coming
up is ABS I don't even know what this
means Abe but it says LFO Summer Girls I
thought we were doing a song and not
like an artist at first so that's a song
okay I don't know if you're familiar oh
I'm familiar I I I saw who sung it LFO
LFO oh I I did a series on my YouTube
channel there's a couple different
videos where I I listed the worst songs
of my adolescence and that that was on
the list not not now not to say my
adolescence as in like I listened to
when I was a kid I just remember from
when I was a kid yeah okay that was
easily one of the worst songs I've heard
in my life and so AV oh no it's it's
[__] horrible but I love it okay so
bad I mean you don't recall this song or
I actually I have okay it's that weird
boy band song where they're like Chinese
food makes me sick
horrible for that summer yeah yeah one
of the lines is yeah I do stayed all
summer then went back home Macaulay
Culkin was at home alone wow that
there's bars
that's fire
okay well so this is a total
denounciation I think which could be
fair means that your admission is a
really good one well hold on a second
I'll I'll say in the I'll say in the
instance of LFO Summer Girls it's it's
sort of like Tommy wiseau's the room
yeah it's one of those things with an
art generally it's it's so bad it
becomes is that what you meant yeah it's
100 yes the amount of joy that it brings
me when people hear for the first time
is that when they are like wait the
lyric said what does it lyrics it makes
you want to die it is the genre of music
I call Shrek Rock they're kind of the
predecessor to that with like the fast
talking rhymy kind of what's the one
what's another example of of Shrek rock
well it was the the most famous one
would be uh is it Greta Van Fleet Smash
Mouth Smash Mouth is like oh smash
essential Shrek got it yeah okay yeah
yeah got it yeah
what's their famous one from Shrek they
go uh All-Stars yeah yeah that's like
quintessent that is true but that song
is Amazing so you you approve of
All-Star yeah All-Star is the best uh
did you win did you see he like Heil
Hitler recently had like a biker rally
oh I didn't see that yeah he's falling
pretty hard man he's in the he's still
stuck in the swamp that's that's rough
he was like blackout drunk piling Hitler
on stage it wasn't good the Smash Mouth
guy yeah the Smash Mouth about that was
a rough time for him Olivia I'm not sure
this is controversial but she says
Selena Gomez I think
I feel like she's not necessarily
esteemed as like the musical
Artist Artist she's more of like an
actress right like I wouldn't I wouldn't
necessarily put this on in the car if
I'm trying to Super impress someone oh
oh well sure so that's that's what I
took as guilty pleasure got it
what do you think
um I mean as far as like I mean it's
like just some Disney Pop right Disney
pop that doesn't sound good I mean
that's like you know it's not it's not
there's worse things that you could
listen to It's not like you know okay
it's it's not toxic it's not harmful
it's not weird okay I feel like there's
a certain age at which listening to that
sort of thing is okay and people who
grew up on that stuff still have still
still have like a soft spot in their
heart for us and so at what age does it
stop being okay I I would say once you
become a teenager but again
I'm 23. you're not it she's not but if
it's something that you grew up on she
has grown up and her music has I think
she has good taste are you trying are
you talking about later cuts and stuff
like I'm talking about like rare the
album I thought it was good okay there
you go but but again if it's something
that like you know it was part of your
musical diet during a foreign it's fine
there it is uh there's a lot of [__]
that I listen to that is is quite
frankly pretty bad but because I
listened to it when I was a kid I still
have like a soft spot for it like what
you want to give us like like that bad
Bush or oh yeah but um wait you like
Bush but you don't like Creed oh no when
I was a kid when I was a [__] child
like you still [__] with that
um yeah the song machine head but
um uh also uh also um uh that band
mindless self-indulgence oh [__] yes God
I listen to that I listened to that when
I was a kid and uh like obviously now I
can still like appreciate it when I
think when I put myself back into 14
year old brain mode but uh bro when I
was when I was when you're when you're
pushing 40 uh [__] love me because
they know that I can rock like that it
doesn't it doesn't hit as hard
but you know what
um
this is actually a it's not I don't like
this music anymore I'm happy to say I
grew out of it but I owned Limp Bizkit
album yeah so did I you did yeah okay so
I wasn't the only I I feel like any
angry or sort of like any teenage boy
during that era looking for some kind of
like you know Suburban teenage boy
looking for an outlet was into some kind
of rap metal do you remember he did a
rap song with Method Man yeah that was
one of the biggest singles it was I
didn't know that that was one of the big
singles off the Record that was [__]
insane like Limp Biscuit rapping with
Method Man it was so weird at the time
people I mean obviously like probably
some hits together now yeah yeah
probably some hip-hop heads were batting
an eye but like you know the the people
who that music was meant to appeal to
were cool with it you know at that time
I liked that I liked um I loved raging
as the machine uh they're highly uh but
the thing is when you're 11 12 you don't
know the [__] difference you know
right right all you all you know is
there's an angry eye rapping over a rock
song you know it's uh so obviously as
I've gotten older I enjoy rage's music
still to this day yeah but you know when
I was when you're a kid you don't really
you're not really delineating you're not
ready to take down the uh
the uh capitalistic uh systems at 12.
you know like I at the time I was well
aware of some of the content of their
music and that it was like political in
nature but like you know I didn't
necessarily see Limp Bizkit as corny I
just saw it as like more and yeah
yeah it was another band called
non-point that I liked at the time I
liked corn as well it was a lot of rap
metal that I liked when I was a kid so
um can't this one's cams I'm not sure
how I'm embarrassing this one is it's a
genre of music 80 to 90s Norwegian black
metal
is that pretty Niche I mean it could be
cringe depending on sort of like the
philosophical or the ideology of the
band because yeah a lot of those guys
have shown themselves to be pieces of
[__] over the years and they're like too
self-serious and racist yeah exactly so
[__] but I I like um like
a big one's dark Throne I still listen
to Dark Throne a lot but you can't
listen like [__] like barg vickerness is
[__] anymore because he's been
proven to be a piece of [__] you know
the thing is like a lot of those people
come from Pagan backgrounds or at least
that's how they see themselves and you
know in their own minds they're
revolting against kind of this Christian
encroachment upon their culture on top
of it they live in very isolated
secluded areas where anything that's new
or different to them is weird so of
course and of course like there's a lot
of like obsession with Heritage for some
of those people so you know anybody
coming from a different cultural
background is seen as like lesser than
because you know there's like a
superiority complex so there's a little
so this is actually potentially really
white uh this is the way this this is
the white supremacy music I have so much
of a bias you have a little bit of a
bias right exactly and I will say I I
listen similar to you I listen to it as
a kid without realizing the underlying
context of the backstory behind a lot of
it so I don't listen to much of it
anymore but yeah it was just an
edgy-formative thing at the time and you
know and and to be fair there are some
artists you know from uh that scene that
you know don't [__] with that ideology
or didn't make it a point in their music
to have anything to do with it yeah and
as it has uh you know become
more of a point of uh obvious
polarization uh you know have distance
themselves from it or have just
continued to make sure that they have
nothing to do with it there are some
people from that uh scene who over the
years have come out of the closet as
well you know it's but they but they you
know are still respected in the scene
and stuff so um you know uh it just just
stay away from the [__] essentially
there it is yeah just do your homework
when you're looking up bands uh there's
one more love he lives in Sweden so this
one's called dude mark
yeah I figured since I'm Swedish I had
to represent and I think you know what
thirdmark is I'm guessing I'm unfamiliar
oh there it is
Young Dudes
isn't that like their punk band yeah
they got their bangers they got some
bangers yeah it's very good and I don't
know if it's good if you don't sound
embarrassed at all though no I I mean
young lean if I were to just show a
young lean song to anyone I feel like
lean
are we talking about young lean because
he's famous yeah he has what he's what
he's referring to is a side project punk
band that he's in oh okay okay I see
yeah
yeah it's it's really good and I I am a
little bit embarrassed when I show just
young lean in general because I think um
I don't know it's very an acquired taste
I guess are you talking about like over
there
is is he not is he not worshiped like a
god you're his work worship
I mean he's worshiped pretty much
everywhere I suppose yeah
uh I don't know just people who haven't
heard of him before it's kind of he
should run for president over there
all right thank you I want to ask you
actually a question about young lean
okay because when this song came out I
thought it was cool I mean I know it's
not the best music in the world but at
the time like any of my friends who I
knew who were into hip-hop okay thought
it was the dumbest [__] and we're like
like dude this is embarrassing don't
show me this [__] right like that bad
you know what I mean and so something
like Kyoto which came out
um nine years ago right were you [__]
with this or what do you think I was not
[__] heavy with young lean's early
stuff I mean this is his most viewed I I
guess I'll say this like I did mess with
Cloud rap generally
I just think there were more interesting
Cloud rap artists okay okay you know
that actually brought some maybe some
better lyrics to the table but like I
mean I like the aesthetic I get the
aesthetic yeah it's it's got a lot of
there's there's a lot of there's a lot
of style to it there is you know I mean
play some of it I mean I mean yeah yeah
don't get it I can't get in trouble I'll
say this like a lot of the production
from that era especially the Clans
Casino stuff was just amazing
game-changing beats you know but at that
time you know young lean is you know
often championed while I think
unfortunately
um a lot of people or a lot of younger
listeners who you know enjoy his stuff
to this day have kind of like you know
fallen off in terms of like also
recognizing the contributions from like
Lil B or ASAP Rocky in terms of his
early stuff which I mean I I sort of
understand because ASAP is kind of you
know transitioned into other sounds as
well and Lil B isn't uh you know quite
as Poppin as he used to be but um you
know I I think uh there should be
acknowledgment of artists that I think
have made more significant contributions
uh as far as like the cloud rap thing
okay well there it is
Anthony Santano
finally
got all of his opinions got all my
opinions and I made it here yes sir you
could check me off your smash list I
heard you're going to uh Hassan's stream
yeah doing that tomorrow nice yeah
yeah that
he's super boring bro so just be
prepared to sit there he wants he wants
to go to the gym with me oh for real
yeah you think
can you bench are you can you bench a
lot I can bench I don't know if I'm
thinking about no probably not probably
cannot bench him
you're going to therapy gecko tonight
I'm going to therapy tonight so you're
all your schedule is jammed it's a whole
it's a whole new media tour that's
awesome yeah well uh Anthony fantano the
busiest music nerd who's on YouTube you
know where he is I mean are you you have
any projects go on YouTube yeah hell
yeah
um uh we're on Twitch we're on Tick Tock
the needle talk
um we're just pumping out content all
the time there it is the reviews are
still the bread and butter and that's
what we're doing
is I want to try to pay you off for a
good review
um mostly just sort of like smaller
people who are just like who just kind
of presume that like out of the gate
that's how things work right how much do
you pay for a review okay uh we don't
have you ever been offered did any of
them ever offer you like an insane
amount of money or anything like I don't
know maybe some like [__] Rich
obscure weirdo like at one time not
anybody anyone would care about but of
course like I said no you know it's like
there's never been an instance where
like some guy like Drake is like
I'll pay you this for the review or I'll
rate your existence of light one you
know it's like not nothing like that
is all right Anthony thank you so much
for coming by it was really nice to
finally got a chance to to meet face to
face in the chat uh lots of love for you
lots of admirers here in the podcast
we're all fans of what you do and the
audience loves you as well so keep it up
stay busy
that's what I'm gonna do and um we'll be
watching thank you so thank you guys
it's Friday happy Friday [__] baby [__]
um anything going on next week Dan the
tease uh Our Guest next Friday it never
mind I'm Olivia's going but to me no
okay it's not completely confirmed but
we might have a very interesting guest
next week
um I don't even know what you guys are
talking about I'll tell you after this
show yeah hopefully it'll work out and
um we have somebody on Monday calling in
Olivia's lipping to me but I still don't
know what it is
uh John Buckley the watch Tick Tock
dudes calling it on Monday oh fun I love
him yeah big fan
Olivia's typing it to me I'll leak it oh
that is a okay yeah
yes
we can't say it why can't we say it
because I guess it's not it's we'll talk
about it thank you guys have a great
weekend we'll see you all on Monday for
another action-packed week of content
laughs spoofs Goofs bomb threats and
um
no what one of the invitations no
hostage videos all right
spot
[Music]
s